yeah i mean it was kind of a full-length  cinema film yeah what did we do so  private jet tables raiders game tables  poor beach clubs  [Laughter]  [Music]  here we go  [Music]  bucks let's start off black or red black  over under getting there 445  over i'm taking the under double nothing  double or not  you've lost every bed since we've been  on this trip  get him out of the way  you you think you can beat him to me  i ain't lost to mikey yet  i'm just here to live  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  taxi race 150 bucks even us  you guys are breaking walls  in 10 minutes and close you get a good  tip for that  make or miss i got missed i gotta make  let's go  bucket no bucketing  i won money because i picked the  opposite side  [Music]  mikey led us to the promised land a  little bit i'm not gonna lie it's just  gotta go next time  five years in a row  [Music]  [ __ ] out of las vegas